now liberals today think that americans
especially white americans are pretty
much the worst thing out there in other
words anyone who doesn't sign on to the
view that america is fundamentally
racist and evil
expect them to be called a white
supremacist and then publicly vilified
for example according to a new book
biden assessed fox news
as one of the most destructive forces in
the united states
and reporters jonathan martin and
alexander burns write that biden was
even more critical of fox court
patriarch rupert murdoch telling an
unnamed associate last year that murdoch
was the most dangerous man in the world
think about that think about what that
really means
more dangerous than putin
more dangerous than she more dangerous
than kim jong-un
okay
and as the angle has told you many times
today's democrat party believes that
conservatives are a far bigger threat to
america than the most powerful dictators
in the world we warned you about this
and remember more evil than the
dictators who have nuclear weapons
pointed at the united states
well and we were right
now
but some people require more direct
proof now let's take the case of andrew
sullivan the supremely talented writer
and well-known commentator who wrote the
seminal book for gay marriage and is
vehemently anti-trump
perhaps he thought that his withering
criticism of trump would have earned him
fair treatment as a guest on a show
hosted by the ever snarky john stewart
but he was wrong
instead for merely insisting that the
story of america is not one of
irredeemable evil
he was annihilated
here's how it all started
jon stewart paying homage to the race
gods of the blm movement
the problem with white people
for however sincerely we want to reckon
and listen
the truth is america has always
prioritized white comfort over black
survival black people have had to fight
so hard for equality
that they've been irreparably set back
in the pursuit of equity
and any real attempt to uh rep
rep
repair
a ton of
that damage
reparation
sets off white peoples they're coming
for our alarm
now the panel is on set nodded along and
they themselves hit all the hot buttons
arguing that white supremacy is alive
and well in the united states well
andrew sullivan hit back and defended
america it's very hard to agree with
some of the very premises
that are being expressed tonight
as if everything is already settled we
know this country is for example a white
supremacy
well i don't believe that
i think it's possibly the the most
absurd hyperbole
i've ever heard
i come from i'm an immigrant so i have a
slightly different view of this i can
tell you america
in 2022
is the most multiracial multicultural
tolerant diverse melting pot that has
ever existed on planet earth and there
is no other place on earth even like it
that's why 86 percent
of our immigrants are non-white let me
see let me ask you a question though
andrew
now reasonable points all well expressed
but not to the other panelist a woman
named lisa bond who makes a living
lecturing other white women about how
racist they are
she was deeply offended that a white man
would try to argue that the u.s is not
systemically racist
this is what happens when you don't talk
about it
white people don't talk about it is you
have
racist dog whistle tropes like this that
actually perpetuate and perpetuate and
put that together so i am i i and i did
not come on this on this show to sit
here and argue with another white man
that's one of the reasons that we don't
even engage with white men at race to
dinner
um
you know because quite honestly if white
men were going to do something about
racism you had 400 years you could have
done it
okay
um
i'm shutting you down right now um
oh he said i'm not responsible for
anyone before me
that is a trigger warning
we have an awful history
it's it's remnants are still you have a
great history john say it again but you
also have a great history but i think
you're minimizing it
calling today white supremacy you are
minimizing actual white supremacy andrew
you're not living on the same planet we
are
[Applause]
i think you are not living in the planet
most americans are which is why this
kind of extremism
right this anti-white extremism yes is
losing popular support is creating a
backlash is going to elect republicans
and undo a lot of the good you think
you're doing
now sullivan is right he might have
asked steward a graduate of william and
mary
if stewart had burned his old diploma on
his soccer jerseys after all the college
was built in part
by slave labor and some of its
presidents owned slaves
i don't care if we say we're progressive
i don't care if you're literally members
of the k
kkk every single white person upholds
these systems and structures of white
supremacy and we have got to talk about
it
if i could finger snap i would finger
snap right now
uh
let's remove it again i'm not calling me
a racist john let's
you're you've been doing a pretty good
job with it yourself there so
yeah so that's where we are in america
that woman is passed off as some type of
expert in anything
and you're a white supremacist or a
racist if you don't agree with jon
stewart that
immigrants shouldn't be blamed for
slavery
this is the ongoing scam of the
anti-racism movement ibrahim kennedy
nicole hannah jones they get paid
handsome sums to tell corporate and
academic audiences how awful to the core
they all are
and they now have thousands of acolytes
across the country who are also eager to
cash in as well
or who like stuart just enjoy the moral
superiority they feel by calling
everyone else a racist
so if you refuse to buy into the ally
ship don't you love that word and the
privilege lingo if you refuse to say
that you support reparations
you are as despicable as any slave
holder from the early 1800s that is what
they believe you think i'm exaggerating
well check out what jon stewart's team
posted on his own show's twitter feed
the problem with white people is
everything the problem with white people
is the inherent defense mechanisms that
pop up to protect privilege anytime race
equity or racist systems come up i.e i
never owned slaves i think the real
problem with white people is how deeply
entrenched privilege exists in their
everyday lives and how terrified they
are to lose it
the only thing funny about jon stewart
these days is how blissfully
self-unaware he is
now this guy
was so afraid of debating andrew
sullivan one on one that he needed to
have the whole situation be like a three
against one then he tagged him as a
white supremacist
and he's the same sneering prig who 18
years ago lectured the host of crossfire
on cnn about the need for more
respectful more informed discourse
well today he's just another race
activist desperate for credibility and
in america that as andrew said is the
most multicultural multi multi-ethnic
that it's ever been
he and almost the entire democrat party
radicalized by the fringes rail against
the old pernicious practice of redlining
while they essentially hoped to redline
their political opponents
instead of trying to win over america
first populous or independents like
sullivan or someone let's say like a
glenn greenwald
they try to destroy them
or make them so toxic that they can't
even make a living in any mainstream
setting again
these people see no logical
inconsistency in the fact that the ccp
is still active on twitter
while trump maybe someone like sullivan
is banned
in fact they're fine with that they have
to ban trump they have to investigate
them they have to hope to prosecute him
put him in jail anything
anything but debate him
and try to defend their abysmally
horrible record running our schools our
cities and the country
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else